joining me now in the studio very
pleased to see Graham Stewart of course
climate minister at Minister great to
have you in the program
um as I mentioned to you whilst we're in
the break there's an awful lot we can
talk about certainly on your brief but
but I do still want to to return to
where we've started every interview this
week and that's the situation at manston
can we just confirm what Robert generic
seemed to imply last night that right
now manston is is operating illegally
people are being detained there for
longer than the 24 hours that you're
entitled to do under the law uh we've
seen I think it's a 77 77 increase in
the number of um people uh in the uh
Crossings and Asylum Seekers
um we've seen this unacceptable surge in
small boats which would which is why the
Prime Minister was talking to the French
President last week why we've um uh
working with the Albanian authorities
the system is is struggling to cope and
that's exactly why we brought in the
nationality and borders bill in order to
have a One-Stop processing that's why
we've got the Rwanda policy um that's
why we're but it is not where we want it
to be right right now and we're we're we
are simply looking to bounce that up and
uh thousands more hotel rooms have been
um sorted out but it's uh it's it's
unacceptable to the British people uh
and we need to do more to tackle the the
traffickers in what is an unprecedented
surge in illegal no one is dating no one
is doubting that this government is it
is ramping up its response and there's
no trying to deal with the situation at
manston but this is what Robert generic
told my colleague Sophie Ridge last
night I expect manston will be returned
returned to a well-functioning and
legally compliant site very rapidly are
you personally happy that the government
in which you serve is currently
detaining Asylum Seekers for that is
what they are at manston that he is
detaining them illegally are you are you
personally comfortable with that well
obviously not none of us are comfortable
with it we wanted to we want it tackled
we want to get a grip that's exactly
what the the home secretary's focused on
I think she's got her priorities right
and that's making sure that we we do
continue to treat people in a
compassionate way but fundamentally
behind this of course there are all
these illegal gangs and um British
people look on it with disbelief
including including the council leaders
down in Kent they've written this letter
to the home office last night just there
are a couple of bits in it that are that
the leap out put simply there says Kent
is at Breaking Point secondary schools
in Canterbury and Ashford currently have
no year seven and year nine places for
local children due to the unexpected and
therefore unplanned for arrivals of
refugee children they also mentioned
that there are around about 20 000 on
waiting lists for Council housing there
we're now talking about local children
not being able to get access to their
school on a human level why has the
government let this situation develop I
understand that there has been a ramping
up of numbers but it has been a pretty
consistent ramping up of numbers it's
not been some overnight exponential rise
well there has been an incredible surge
but one of the reasons for bringing in
dispersal which is one of the policies
to make sure that every local Authority
right around this country shares in
taking on this burden it is immense and
we recognize that the people of Kent and
public services in Kent should not be
carrying that burden alone and that's
why we're looking to bring in all these
measures
um and uh you know that is that is our
Focus that's the home secretary's Focus
we're not claiming it's acceptable right
now and that's why we're taking steps to
put it right just one just one other
thing to people popping the screen then
and of course we've mentioned albanians
and there is certainly a feeling that a
significant number of those who have
been coming here have been coming here
for for criminal reasons well you know
Albania's prime minister ready Ram is
not desperately happy about this he
tweeted this last night Albania is not a
rich country and was for a very long
time a victim of Empires we never had
our own we have a duty to fight crime at
home and are doing so resolutely as
cooperating closely with others too
ready to work closer with the UK but but
facts are crucial
um so is mutual regret I think we may
have the wrong one there but in essence
what what the Albanian prime minister is
suggesting is that perhaps some of the
rhetoric that is being directed at his
fellow countrymen and women might just
be slightly over the top well I'm
grateful for the um uh the work we're
doing with the albanians and they have
been sending senior police
officers over so as to speed up
processing we've got a expedited system
to return albanians if it turns out that
they are not legitimate Asylum Seekers
so we are trying to work in cooperation
but clearly there's pressure you can see
it from the councils you can see it from
uh members of parliament you can hear it
from people people and journalists
around the country it can lead to
language which is sometimes unfortunate
and it is worth putting on record our
gratitude to the Albanian government for
their cooperation
um in working to sort the sound let's
let as as promised move on to your brief
How concerned were you uh by the UN
emissions Gap report that emerged
yesterday
um well we're absolutely focused on
making sure that the Glasgow climate
pact is converted into action
um and as you say the world is not on
track for 1.5 degrees
um
2.8 degrees report after report after
report
um and that is why I mean why have we
taken the actions we've taken we've cut
our emissions in this country
domestically we're only a small part of
the globe but setting an example by more
than any other major economy on Earth
but also we're also learning we're also
you know opening opening up the bidding
process for for 100 new kind of gas and
oil extraction licenses in the North Sea
that doesn't sit very comfortably with a
commitment to Net Zero it doesn't look
like it does it absolutely does we're
committed to a uh a 50 reduction in
emissions around production in the North
Sea we're managing the decline of the
Basin it is expected with new licenses
that it'll still be reducing at about
seven percent a year faster than the
globe needs to cut its oil and gas and
producing our own energy here to ever
hire environmental standards
um stopping us spending billions on
bringing in oil and gas from other
countries it's a weird argument when you
you're going to have to burn oil and gas
up to 2050 and through 2050 even on Net
Zero to think that buying it from abroad
is somehow Superior from doing it at
home well it's going to be sold in the
same Market we're not going to get it
cheaper just because it's produced it's
not about being it's not being about
being cheaper but you're buying it from
the international market and what you're
you're buying it if you have domestic
production I mean are the tax on that at
the moment 65 I mean it is 7 billion
from the from the windfall Levy that was
brought in
um a 10 billion next year
um it really is worth nailing Neil the
idea that us as part of a declining
Basin producing our own oil and gas when
we have Net Zero in our law when it
doesn't affect our consumption and when
we are net importers that that is
somehow bad it isn't and I really would
like to nail it I hope your viewers at
home would see that us producing our own
oil and gas to ever higher standards
leading to technology which is then
exported around the rest of the world is
a good thing I know it sounds ironic I
get marked in the newspaper no no I'm
climate Minister says more oil and gas
is good for the environment in that
context it is and it's a it's an
argument worth making and I'll tell you
what people in Northeast Scotland want
they understand that argument and to see
the Scottish government wanting to
abandon them and having this argument
made out as if they are part of the
problem they are part of the transit we
live in Aberdeen who point to the fact
that Rishi sunak has said that he
doesn't want solar Farms on Farmland
that doesn't strike me as particularly I
I was particularly pushing towards net
zero he's also said that he is going to
scrap the pan the plans to relax the ban
on onshore wind which is by my Reckoning
and indeed by by other people's
Reckoning the cheapest form of renewable
energy now those are two ways in which
we could dramatically increase renewable
clean energy production in this country
and he said no to it five minutes after
entering Downing Street what we are
committed to Growing our Renewables
which we've done more than anyone else
well we are doing it on land and we're
seeing solar I mean make getting the
balance right between uh farmland and
solar is something that we're working on
and when we have further details to
share we'll do so but uh actually the
cheapest current form of renewable is uh
you know uh on on ground solar with
onshore wind being just behind an
onshore wind is our largest single
renewable
um sector with 14 gigawatts coming from
it can you confirm that which we've been
hearing in the papers this morning but
actually the Prime Minister the chance
that I have been listening to kyostarma
and that they are going to expand the
scope of of the windfall tax on the
energy Giants Well I could be absolutely
clear that I don't think we'd go
listening to Kia stama but we do always
keep these things under review but on
fiscal matters I leave that to my
treasury colleagues and we will doubt we
will hear more on the 17th of November
just just one final word um from you on
Matt Hancock who I know healing is
getting 400 000 pounds for appealing on
Amazon yeah I'm a celebrity that's
nearly five times his his MP salary look
is there perhaps a degree of hypocrisy
from the conservative whips office
they've removed the whip from Matt
Hancock for going to Australia they
didn't remove it from Boris Johnson for
going to the Caribbean on a holiday he
wasn't doing anything about dyslexia or
indeed from Liz truss who I'm reliably
informed is also abroad on her Halls
well we think that MPS should be
attending to their duties
and of course with so many people
working from home these days it is
possible uh to work from wherever you
are in the world it's not really
possible to do that when you're in the
jungle he wouldn't have had the whip
removed have been able to take a laptop
in so you can answer these constituents
emails uh I think while you're eating
various worms and sticking your head in
unpleasant places it's quite hard Neil
to concentrate on what's going on in
your Suffolk constituency I I will tell
you it will be a a nation unifying event
of that I am sure Minister it's been
great to have you in the program thanks
for being with us thank you